I started Facebook.
I run it and I'm responsible for what happens here.
How do you sustain a business model in which users don't pay for your service?
Senator, we run ads.
Here's what everybody's been trying to tell you today, and I say this gently:...
...Your user agreement sucks.
The purpose of that user agreement is to cover Facebook's rear end.
It's not to inform your users about their rights.
Now, you know that and I know that.
We don't sell data at all.
But this is widely mischaracterized about our system,...
...that we sell data...
...and it's actually one of the most important parts of how Facebook works...
...is we do not sell data.
Advertisers do not get access to people's individual data.